[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
sur tv 60,18 radio sensations et les
internet bien sûr nous allons aborder
plusieurs cision va parler évidemment
des élections départementales peut-être
surtout des élections régionales de leur
dimension politique on va parler aussi
de l'antenne du cevipof
pas de ça la france de macron une france
un peu désespéré ça fait sourire
derrière les anglais de voir à quel
point nous sommes désespérés alors que
sont tout à fait heureux d'être vacciné
et puis on parlera peut-être aussi du
complotisme qui est toujours de retour
qui est un sujet une sorte de serpent de
mer et pour en parler
accueil véronique 0e bonjour vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'université de
paris saclay vous est ce qu'on appelle
polique tout économiste et vous êtes le
responsable du site élections scop c'est
à dire que vous êtes une chercheuse en
analyse économique de la politique et
vous est cofondatrice avec bruno jérôme
du site donc élections secousse coop et
otero vous êtes totalement presse de de
sciences politiques d'un livre sur les
municipales villes de droite villes de
gauche et vous avez publié tout
récemment à un article dans le figaro un
article excellent sur les sur les
critères de choix des électeurs aux
élections régionales voilà j'ai dit à
peu près tout vous vous présenter et
merci d'être avec nous les jeunes on
ajoute anne vous est aussi directrice de
la communication du compte twitter
paul quatre castings qui donne la vie
pendant que le fantastique bien fort oui
c'est vrai le forum et 20 pour le force
à fait poète donc paul fort bonne forme
d'essai de six frégates un casting qui
donne la visibilité aux travaux des
membres de l' american political science
association
j'ai été complet d'après patrice merci
merci infiniment merci beaucoup à djerba
bezina duclair bonjour vous êtes
d'autres d'autres conférences à
l'université de rouen est notamment
l'auteur de textes concis
constitutionnelles et politiques aux
éditions thémis and perdriau bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes planté de la tresse
conseillère régionale sortante je peux
dire de deux villes de france et donc on
ne voit pas les élections régionales
votre témoignage sera précieux vincent
couronne bonjour êtes vous êtes vous
êtes enseignant journaliste et fondateur
des surligneurs qui traque les fake et
défèquent pas news mais l'effet que
paroles je peux dire notamment d'aider
des hommes et des femmes politiques et
jean charles lajoie dit bonjour c'est un
peu long comme présentation mais on a du
lourd
je voulais présenter un peu plus au
gouverneur 0 mais qui qui qui nous fait
le plaisir d'être notre invité vous êtes
visiteurs absolument et ben voila tient
le dernier dernières parutions des
éditions la joie ni une nuit sans fin
derrick savez vous savez un passionnant
impressionnant vivre très très astucieux
et c'est dans la collection vraiment pas
policier mais presque cers et appelle
n'y a pas d' enquête mais un type à
qu'il arrive très très drôle d'histoire
c'est un type qui roule et qui va
heurter un un scooter value heurté le
type tombe à terre et le type est dans
sa voiture il pleut il va sortir pour le
sauver il peut le sauver
oui toi ne pas le sauver voilà suspense
suspense a démarré là ok alors on va
parler tout à fait autre chose et on va
revenir justement sur ces élections
départementales et régionales et sur les
conséquences ou les enjeux politiques et
économiques de ces élections c'est le
premier dossier de cette émission
[Musique]
alors verdict clément va revenir sur
l'article que vous avez publié avec
bruno jérôme dans le dans le figaro mais
auparavant il faut peut-être distinguer
les élections départementales des
élections régionales on a tendance à les
confondre parce que elles sont
concomitants elles sont organisées le
même jour mais ce sont deux élections
absolument différentes et dans leurs
enjeux politiques et même dans les
compétences peuvent êtres vincent
couronne en en un mot quelles sont les
compétences d'aider des conseils
départementaux et quelles sont les
compétences des conseils régionaux alors
en un mot patrie ça va être un peu un
peu difficile mais j'ai quand même et
j'ai quand même essayé alors les bouts
de grandes tendances on va dire les
départements c'est essentiellement des
questions sociales mais pas que parce
que c'est un mélange et érotique était
rempli de compétences qui a été calé pas
mal évolué au fil des différentes
majorités politiques se sont succédé au
gouvernement
mais la moitié du budget des
départements aujourd'hui c'est le social
avec par exemple le rsa la question de
deux lettres pour les handicapés pour
les personnes âgées etc
les maisons de retraite par exemple les
régions elles de leur côté c'est
essentiellement l'économie et donc elles
sont chefs de file pour le développement
économique mais elles ont aussi dans
l'oeuf à dire que elles vont par exemple
aider les entreprises elles vont même
aidé à l'innovation scientifique par
exemple ce sont elles qui gèrent les
pôles de compétitivité
il y en a 8 à rien qu'à saint quentin en
yvelines par exemple et puis c'est aussi
la culture avec la promotion des langues
régionales on a vu il ya quelques jours
des manifestations un peu partout en
france sur la question d'enseignement
des langues immersive et puis la
question les transports aussi pour les
régions qu'il a pourrait s'inviter à un
moment donné dans la campagne avec la
question de l'ouverture à la concurrence
des transports des transports régionaux
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que en
tout cas la sécurité contrairement à ce
que beaucoup des affiches de candidats
et de programme de candidate en pas nous
faire croire n'est pas une compétence ni
des régions ni des départements
oui vous avez réseau et c'est pourtant
le crème un peu essentiel de cette
campagne est ce qu'on peut dire que il
ya permet d'y édiles qui est que le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines dit au fond le le le les
élections départementales c'est le
troisième tour des municipales
c'est dire que c'est ce dont des
élections vraiment locale et puis que
les élections régionales sont des
élections peut-être plus politique
alors je trouve que cette phrase est
bien trouvé en effet les départementales
sont vraiment de loin les mal aimés de
nos élections le département en général
est d'ailleurs l'échelon le moins connu
de la population celui qui emporte le
moins de nos convictions de la part des
citoyens et c'est vrai que très souvent
ça reste à forte connotation locale on
n'entend pas vraiment en parler de ces
élections comme étant un véritable enjeu
al'inverse les régionales par l'ampleur
des débats et notamment par l'ampleur
des collectivités dont on monte on parle
à ce moment là et bien non plus susciter
des enjeux politiques qui peuvent se
rapprocher des enjeux nationaux
mais là encore souvent comme laboratoire
des futures élections présidentielles
les élections régionales sont un peu un
prisme déformant parce qu'elle ça arrive
un peu tôt dans la précampagne
présidentielle alors sauf pour cette
année et donc on a parfois des faux
espoirs de succès qui ne se concrétisent
pas donc en tout cas oui il ya cette
idée que les régionales vont amener vos
draguer des éléments plus important du
débat mais c'est pas toujours un
baromètre tout à fait fidèle de la
présidentielle non plus alors verdict
j'ai revu dans votre article vous
montrez très bien
l'affluence au fond de la situation
politique nationale sur le résultat des
élections régionales par exemple 86 92
mitterrand est très impopulaire et la
gauche perd les des élections régionales
2010 sarkozy est impopulaire victoire du
ps aux élections régionales 2015
situation inverse impopularité et de
françois hollande et victoire de la
droite aux élections régionales
au fond il ya un vrai bosseur alors on
va venir ce qu'il peut se passer
maintenant en 2020 21 b il ya vraiment
une influence très forte quoi s'est
établi en tout cas on a toujours observé
cette incapacité pour un exécutif
national a gagné ces élections gagner
ces élections nationales
néanmoins force est de constater que ce
sont des élections et les élections
régionales en particulier
on dit souvent qu elles sont des
élections fin avec l'élection scop en
tout cas ce sont des élections
nationales localisée parce que vous
citiez évinçant le disais il ya des
aspects économiques mais il ne reste pas
moins que les régions sondées entre
guillemets d'edena économique au sens où
le budget de la région dans le budget le
budget régional dans le budget local
ce n'est que deux ans et demi pour cent
le budget du département c'est 5% et le
budget de la région dans le budget total
dans la dépense publique totale c'est
13% pour la région et 1 6% pour le
département ça reste peu de choses
en 2015 le budget régional c'était 1 300
du pib donc c'est très faibles donc la
compétence de la région au plan
économique il y à des reconnaissances de
compétences mais elle se trouve limité
c'est pourquoi il est compliqué pour les
lecteurs de ne regarder quand il le peut
parce que là encore la visibilité n'est
pas toujours facile étant donné
l'éloignement et encore plus aux
régionales qu départementale où il ya
une forme de proximité avec les
conseillers départementaux avec les
conseils régionaux et les grandes
régions nous pas ajouter aux n'ont pas
aidé plutôt ajouter à l'éloignement donc
les lecteurs a du mal et du mas il va se
se raccrocher à des ressentis qui
viennent d'un contexte et d'un contexte
qui est national
quand c'est de constater que c'est sur
cet aspect qu'il s'appuie alors je
pourrais aller plus loin
si vous le souhaitez sur la
particularité de 2021 ce souci-là les
hérésies oui évidemment alors on à part
dont je vous interromps mais vous
montrer très bien d'ailleurs dans
l'article mais c'est vrai que jusqu'à
présent on avait à la présidence d'alain
public va pouvoir exécutif d'eads et des
gens qui tenait ou qu'ils aient faim qui
fait partie des membres des
représentants de partis qui tenait les
régions qui des deux n'est pas mai et
qui pouvaient l'équipe b les conquérir
or maquereau et le république en marche
ne détiennent aucune région donc ça ça
fait une différence notable alors il n'y
a pas de sortant cette situation on l'a
vu aussi aux municipales et aux
municipales à stratégie était peut-être
plus fort parce qu'il ya eu des
tentatives de rapprochement de soutien
de la part en marche vers certaines
municipalités
ceux qui ont accepté longueur n'ont pas
toujours été chanceux en la matière on
voit ce qui s'est passé avant nous
allions donc c'est pas forcément une
bonne stratégie
de surcroît pourquoi ça ne peut pas être
forcément une bonne stratégie
tout dépend des caractéristiques
économiques et politiques de l'exécutif
national c'est à dire que sur le plan
économique c'est l'évolution du chômage
dont on va considérer qu'une attribution
de responsabilité et là elle sera à
l'exécutif national
mais la région étant très impliqué dans
les aspects apprentissage emploi etc
revendiqué aussi et elle a d'autant plus
intérêt
le président de région a d'autant plus
intérêt à revendiquer que ça se passe
bien sur le forme la décrue du chômage
et là c'est le cas pour certaines
régions et donc il ya toujours moyen de
dire oui bien sûr les politiques sont
décidés en eau par l'exécutif national
mais moi en région j'interprète et jeu
je suis aussi partie prenante aux bons
résultats on peut dire aussi de façon un
peu moins un peu moins courageuse quand
ça se passe mal et il ya aussi le
parapluie le bouc émissaire des dix ans
va finalement les décisions pourraient
être prises ne même pas sur le terrain
améliorer la situation
et puis le deuxième volet parce que
polito économistes ont qu'a aussi la
politique vu par l'économiste que je
suis le deuxième volet c'est la
politique est là la politique ce qui
m'intéresse le le critère que je prends
je fais comme les lecteurs et j'ai une
idée un ressenti c'est là
pu l'arrêter c'est ce qui est traduit
dans la popularité dans la et là je
devrais dire en l'occurrence dans le
déficit de popularité du président macro
si on compare les satisfaits et les
mécontents il ya un déficit et plus de
mécontents que de satisfaits il est à
moi 22 ce qui est pas le pire des cas
puisque françois hollande nous a montré
pratiquement déchets un déficit de
popularité carrément double al'approche
des des régionales mais l'idée c'est de
dire que ce déficit de popularité
finalement il est une nouvelle pour
l'opposition est là pour les oppositions
et la droite et la gauche puisque
l'opposition sont ces partis de
gouvernement et le parti majoritaire lui
n'a pas n'a pas de pardon
les sortants de droite et de gauche
peuvent tirer avantage de cette faille
dans la popularité de l'exécutif c'est
cette popularité d'exécutif peut agir
comme un game challenge à du score de de
l'issue du scrutin et et en même temps
je voulais ajouter une chose mais je
veux dire que j'ai perdu j'ai perdu le
fil oui donc là c'est cette popularité
peut agir comme un gamin et je veux je
voulais ajouter que les en marche
non pas dix enfants maison des candidats
et ensuite ce sera toujours la stratégie
les choses pourraient s'engager hélas la
stratégie elle est très compliqué parce
que en marche pourrait avoir envie le
candidat en marche pourrait avoir envie
de s'allier avec des sortants de droite
ou de gauche qui ont un bon bilan mais
le sortant n'a pas intérêt à s'allier
avec un candidat marc chisson et bilan
est bon d'ailleurs revendiquent la
responsabilité vis-à-vis des lecteurs il
va pas accepter que quelqu'un vienne m'a
finalement s'allier c'est d'opportunisme
donc pour en marche ce n'est pas
possible
et quand ce serait possible ce ne serait
ni morts uniquement accepté que par des
sortants qui ont un mauvais bilan et qui
se disent ben je vais profiter
finalement de la réputation ou d'une
notoriété d'un candidat en marche qui va
venir m'épauler pour partager le mauvais
bilan mais là c'est le candide en marche
qui va refuser parce qu'il va diriger
aucun intérêt à venir assumer un mauvais
bilan pour lequel je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas de responsabilité partie voilà ce
portrait ce tableau un peu un peu noir
que je peux vous devrez suisse merci
merci beaucoup
un père brio
vous verrez que vous êtes conseiller
régional ile de france vous regarder
évidemment la campagne à votre avis
quand même c'est sur des critères plus
nationaux plus locaux kiki ou plus
régionaux qui préside au vote bv
j'ai envie de vous dire en fait moi ce
que je constate alors c'est une vision
complémentaire et très terrain puisque
je vais quasiment tous les jours à la
rencontre des personnes sur le terrain
pour leur parler un peu politiques des
programmes et rap
on voit qu'il ya vraiment un déficit
considérable de d'éducation citoyenne
j'allais dire et c'est pas du tout une
critique c'est c'est simplement que les
gens ne comprennent rien et que le fait
d'avoir mis départementale et régionale
en même temps si c'est une bonne idée
sur le plan j'allais dire sanitaires et
pratique
c'est vraiment difficile pour le citoyen
de s'y reconnaître
samedi dernier par exemple j'étais à
proximité d'un marché sur le dialogue
avec les gens et c est une dame me dit
non mais moi je suis pas dit si je suis
crêpière mais crêpière à 7 en ile de
france
voyez oui mais alors c'est quoi un
canton on parle de canton c'est quoi un
canton et alors là on a chaque fois
c'est une demi heure d'éducation civique
et je pense que là il ya vraiment il ya
vraiment ce problème là doublé d'un
panorama politique qui est beaucoup
moins blanc noir que le précédent avec
des parties très très traditionnel
j'allais dire et là on voit le travail
de lrn droite gauche et c'est donc on
sait plus trop et les alliances qui se
font sont totalement incohérente entre
départementales et régionales
donc si vous voulez on va soutenir des
gens départementale concon contreras
après pour les présidentielles et si
vous voulez dans la tête des gens
vraiment c'est je ne comprends plus rien
et mêmes les gens n'avaient pas encore
intégré que dans les bureaux de vote
dureraient deux urnes en fait lui remet
des régionales et lui remet des
départementales et voilà donc il ya un
énorme une énorme confusion à ce niveau
là avec avec un risque dans le sol je
vous dis c'est peut-être que le grand
gagnant de ces élections se soient quand
même où l'abstention du combat je crois
et l'éjection de du week-end dernier la
faim qui viennent se dérouler existe at
il lancé c'est une catastrophe
quasiment personne ne se nous serons
vous urnes est ce que diane était est
assez juste je pense que les gens ne
comprennent rien mais ce qui me gêne pas
tellement qu'ils comprennent rien je
sais surtout peur qu'ils s'en foutent
que ça ne les concerne au plus vite
et la raison par exemple si on prend le
cas des yvelines c'est vrai que sur la
liste du président sortant qui est pire
bédié il ya des gens qui vont il ya des
gens du lr m
il ya des gens du modem dont il ya des
gens qui ne vont pas voter pour les
meubles candidats
qui sont sur liste départementale mais
que ne vont pas voter pour les mêmes
candidats aux régionales il est encore
plus aux présidentielles donc c'est vrai
que ça peut compliquer les choses
intellectuellement je pense que se fasse
a induit dans l'esprit des gens une
sorte de dilution des responsabilités et
à dire comme le disait tout à fait
justement vincent tout à l'heure le
département c'est ça la région c'est
autre chose
le député c'est encore une troisième
chose le ski faudrait simplifier
ah ben je devrais je pense qu'une
simplification cliquer qui s'impose
parce que c'est très mais dd il faut
gratter arrive parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on rencontre un homme politique ou
une femme politique est apparu mais ça
c'est ça ça dépend pas de nous là on le
rappelle la sécurité c'est pas nous ça
c'est pas nous et puis après on arrive à
l'échelon ge lors bien supérieur ou au
niveau de l'exécutif qui ont dit ah bah
oui on le ferait bien mais l'europe ne
peut pas il ya toujours quelque chose
qui fait qu'on ne peut pas faire les
choses alors je pense que le le bon
peuple en a un peu marre qu dit bon ça
va
pourquoi se déplacer puisque toute façon
personne ne peut plus rien et sont
tombés d'accord mais même peut-être
peut-être justement sur des élections
locales départementales on se dit voilà
c'est les routes c'est ceci c'est cela
ça peut céder c'est comme les merdes les
restaurants le le maire garde toute son
aura et sa responsabilité parce que lui
on voit ce qu'il fait et des passants à
rien de se défausser visite à c'est vrai
qu'il ya ça fait longtemps un compact du
millefeuille administratif qu'on essaye
de simplifier alors ya eu cette
simplification entre guillemets avec la
réduction du nombre de régions mais ça
va pas changer grand chose
oui en fait mais ça allait bouger sont
accrues de choses si on devait faire un
historique de la décentralisation les
mouvements législatifs ont commencé
depuis 1982 avec rencontrer le parti
pris de revaloriser la région soit on
est à l'échelon technique est bon dans
les premières années
c'est bien fonctionné parce que cette
région elle était facile à identifier il
ya une petite
l'idée de dodo crée aussi des
patrimoines régionaux donc la région à
ce bien réussi son succès d'implantation
néanmoins à partir du moment où on a
rajouté l'échelon régional puis qu'on a
six intercommunalités qui sont dans les
années 90 bien on a eu le sentiment que
les citoyens se plaît dans la complexité
administrative notamment parce que pour
des compétences parfois très très
proches
l'action économique l'action sociale les
transports et la végétalisation de la
vie ou ce genre de choses là est bien le
département la commune
l'intercommunalité de la région et de
l'union européenne pouvait parfois être
cinq fois compétent pour la même chose
donc on s'est vraiment rendu compte de
sa très vite mais aucune volonté
politique n'a vraiment réussi à aboutir
à une fusion des shows ou à une
suppression des chemins on parle de la
suppression du département je pense
depuis des années 2000 et pourtant ça
n'est jamais venu sur le calendrier
politique
il ya eu seulement un projet de loi qui
a été celui de nicolas sarkozy qui
consistait précisément à fusionner les
élections des partants lional un peu
comme on le fait aujourd'hui mais avec
un spray chine aurait été donc du coup
trop conseiller territorial qui aurait à
la fois conseiller régional et
départemental mais sans vraiment
supprimer le département non plus donc
en réalité je pense que ce qui nous
manque dans notre paysage territorial
c'est un courage politique de proposer
vraiment une solution alternative à soi
et régionalisation soit une fusion entre
le département et la région
on en parle mais on fait toujours très
peu de chose là dessus je voulais
ajouter peut-être un point 2-2 politique
c'est à dire qu'on a parlé de la
complexité pour le citoyen et je pense
qu'on ne dit pas assez et l'a très bien
dit on ne dit pas assez à quel point le
parti en marche alors qu'il n'a aucune
attache territoriales a quand même
réussi à brouiller complètement
il fit kg et politique au sens où le
citoyen s'il retrouvait et on a dit tout
à l'heure que des régionales était
parfois on va dire une
à laboratoire d'idées de la
présidentielle où la législative
c'est notamment parce qu'on retrouvait
un peu les mêmes parties les municipales
historiquement ont toujours eu des sans
étiquette des candidats ou à dire plutôt
affectif
alors que les régionales étaient
vraiment des élections avec les partis
présidentiels et c'était un petit peu la
convoyer les joutes se faire sauf que le
véhicule le parti aujourd'hui a de moins
en moins de on va dire de j'ai envie de
dire d'incarnation auprès des citoyens
parce que on ne sait plus qui est à
droite qui est à gauche où il positionne
en est donc ça laisse aussi beaucoup
plus de place à des partis émergents ou
à d'autres types de partie parce que en
fait les citoyens ont juste envie
d'essayer autre chose mais plus vraiment
de d'identification dans les partis
traditionnels
ce que pourtant les régionales et des
affaires très bien donc ces régionales
ne peuvent même plus vraiment nous
servir pour la présidentielle parce
qu'on n'a même plus la tâche et elle est
partie historique du temps lâché 2 de ce
brouillage complet du message politique
je vais être probablement un peu un peu
vulgaire vous avez tout notre assemblée
mais j'aimerais savoir combien coûte et
combien combien ça rapporte et
conseiller départemental combien ça
rapporte de conseiller régional convient
président de deux conseils gagne je
pense que ça serait assez intéressant
pour le brio par d'antiques vous voulez
le révéler vos immense émoluments je
peux vous dire très clairement une
conseillère conseiller régional de base
c'est 1900 euros nets
voilà un président et le prêt le
président je crois que c'est autour de
5000 5300 à peu près de rouen
pareil
il n'ya pas non plus de quoi je reviens
parlez pas de ce qu'on fait je reviens
ce qu'est ce que disait bezina duclair
ou si je vous ai interrogé à tous au
four est ce que la complexité ne vient
pas aussi d'un phénomène politique c'est
à dire que laroque opposition qui a
commencé en 2017 afin qu'elle même était
un une sorte de coup de tonnerre en 2017
ne continue pas et est-ce que c'est pas
ça qui rend les choses difficiles c'est
à dire que on a une sorte de queue de
comète qui sont les villes les régions
ou dans lesquels les partis politiques
traditionnels le lr le ps ont encore un
poids très fort alors que sur le plan
national il s'effondre et il faut place
à des parties de vous comme comme le
parti macro nist par exemple et ça rend
les choses un peu difficiles et cette
recomposition voit bien qu'elle continue
vous avez des gens comme rebsamen le
maire de dijon qui dit prêt à voter pour
macron je parle de gens à gauche à
droite on les a vus avec maire de nice
et serra des le gars qui est la
présidente de d'un nouvel aquitaine ps
aussi et est prête à collaborer pour les
élections présidentielles avec macro
donc on voit bien que cette
recomposition est en marche et que on a
dans ces élections intermédiaires que
sont les élections régionales ont encore
une forte présence de partis plus
traditionnelles qui eux s'effondre sur
le plan national
est ce que vous êtes est ce que vous
partagez cette analyse va commencer par
vous verdict jérôme oui mais j'aurais
voulu je ne voulais ajouter précédent ya
les amis de la vie de l'électeur
ces élections que les c'est entendu
l'électeur est éloigné des
considérations je dirais de terrain et
pour lui il comprend pas bien comment
les choses se passent et encore plus au
niveau de la région peut-être qu'au
niveau du département
néanmoins les lecteurs il a c'est un peu
le dernier rendent avant la
présidentielle il a une occasion de
caricatures de daumier qui disait le
bulletin de vote c'est ma cartouche est
là quoi qu'il arrive et on peut avoir
alors je vais peut être dire un peu
les choses de façon un peu différente de
ce que écrit guillaume tabard dans son
excellente dans son excellent papier de
ce matin il dit finalement quid de
l'abstention et les électeurs
effectivement l'abstention c'est un
élément qui va pouvoir rejouer et ces
élections auront valeur de sondage
grandeur nature
et si l'abstention elle est généralement
au-dessus de 50% que ce soit aux
régionales en 2010 en 2015 mais même au
départemental
l'abstention est très forte on pourrait
imaginer que ça continue et que ça
traduit ce désintérêt des électeurs ou
au contraire un peu à l'image du
déconfinement les lecteurs qui va
retourner sur les terrasses il a
peut-être envie de retourner aux urnes
parce qu'il a peut-être envie de
s'exprimer
il a l'impression d'avoir été un peu ce
dernier en quelque sorte le bayonnais me
faire le terme est trop fort mais le
quand même et il est possible qu'ils
aient envie d'envoyer un signal il doit
se saisir et là ce sera tant pis pour le
sortant quel qu'il soit l'électeur peut
se saisir de ces élections pour envoyer
un signal un peu plus haut pour envoyer
un signal à l'exécutif national en
disant mon ressenti il est il n'est pas
bon non ressenti consiste à dire eh bien
voilà ce qui a été fait ne me convient
pas et au plan national le caler les
choses peuvent s'en mêler donc il ya
caractère un peu barométrique quand même
de ces élections même si on peut pas
dire véritablement ce qui va se passer
si on veut pas d'ailleurs on n'a pas
risqué avec élection scop on n'a pas
risqué et de prévision au sens où on
modélise et du terme
on n'a pas sorti comme on le faisait
habituellement de prévisions parce que
on manque euro manque de recul on a on a
dix candidats en marche on ne sait pas
très bien comment les choses roncq ou
être interprétées par les électeurs mais
néanmoins ce brouillage systématique là
j'essaie de retomber sur votre sur votre
question ce brouillage systématique
quand marché c'est de faire en dix ans
ni de droite ni de gauche mais est de
droite et de gauche en même temps
essayer d'en avoir que bon côté des
choses et de d'évacuer le mauvais côté
des choses c'est une stratégie qui qui
renforce encore le brouillard jaequi qui
nuit à la visibilité
mais je pense que les lecteurs ne sera
pas dupe je pense que les lecteurs
sur le terrain il va s'attacher à la
personnalité aussi quand il connaît
quand il connaît le son conseiller
départemental et bien
il fera peut-être un donnera peut-être
une importance particulière à la
personnalité
il laissera un peu de beauté ni
stratégie maintenant si il y à des
stratégies locales qui ne sont pas
perçus comme étant cohérente avec une
attitude je dirais idéologique
si le l'individu ne se comporte pas sur
le terrain comme de son parti le fait ou
plan national ou s'il ya des alliances
et il ya des alliances qui sont fait un
peu je dirais en off
ces alliances elles peuvent à terme plus
nuire aux candidats que ne lui rapporter
lorsque les lecteurs quand il ne
comprend pas eh bien il peut très
facilement sanctionné je pense qu'une
seule une seule tardera qui ne se mettra
pas de le faire et l'autre poids aussi
quand on parle de l'abstention faut
quand même regarder que sur les
départementales
le critère il est quand même assez fort
pour accéder au second tour
on va avoir un vrai ménage entre premier
et second degrés parce que si on
considère de tête haute dose et demi des
suffrages pour passer au deuxième tour
douze ennemis des suffrages de 6 12 et
mis des annonces et ça c'est 25% des
inscrits pour passer au pur pour pouvoir
être élu mais ses douze des mines et des
inscrits ça signifie 29 % des exprimés
si on a une une abstention très forte de
l'ordre par exemple 57% des si je pousse
instants sont plus forts de ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer si j'ai près de 60%
d'abstention je dois voir près de 30 %
des exprimés pour pouvoir
donc c'est une contrainte qui sera assez
forte donc là il faut considérer aussi
tous ces petits candidats qui n'ont pas
assez de notoriété seront je pense sauf
à fusionner avec l'autre à nice mais
auront du mal à rester nous avez raison
que par exemple opaque car on voit bien
que les alliances
sont peut-être mal comprise ddd des
votants gère la jolie oui juste une
petite question est ce que pour la
république en marche c'est pas
l'occasion rêvée d'engranger un certain
nombre de grands électeurs
c'est intéressant ça et puis elle le
fait de faire le poids si ici parce que
j'avais bertrand ou valérie pécresse par
exemple avait besoin de la république en
marche pour passer c'est vrai que ça
change un peu le renard fleurs leur
stratégie pour la pour la présidentielle
incertaine et vincent et à mon père
pardon juste cette queue de comète je ne
suis pas garanti qu'il existe encore des
partis traditionnels
on verra cela mais je suis plutôt au
contraire de de la vie que vous exposiez
patrice qui consiste à dire que la
recomposition du paysage politique ce
n'est pas justement cette espèce actes
qu'on a eu une 17e est évidemment encore
en cours parce qu'on est en quelque
sorte les vibrations de cet homme qui
sont encore complètement complètement
actuelle je pense qu'on en a pour des
années avant de recomposer un échiquier
et je crois qu'en effet les jeux
d'alliance dans ces régionales ne liront
pas forcément quelque chose de la
présidentielle mais peut-être de l'état
de vie ou de mort de co2 n'ont pas je
crois on n'est pas près de s'en voir la
fin de cette recomposition et de de
cette renaissance ou de cette mort des
partis traditionnels je crois qu'on est
vraiment encore maintenant sachant que
deux des principaux candidats valérie
pécresse et et xavier bertrand ne font
plus partie de l air ou créer leur
propre mouvement
je me demande jusqu'à quel point grave
incendie confirmera sûrement vendre cas
on va pouvoir voir peut-être qu'on
déballe on n'est pas un petit peu en
train de vivre la fin des partis
politiques traditionnels qui
vela a structuré l'échiquier on en avait
l'habitude est pour moi le véhicule du
parti avec tout ce que font les think
tanks les autres réseaux d'aidé le
véhicule du parti commence à devenir un
petit peu un an d'absence
enfin c'est une voilà une idée que je
pose ici j'espère briller ou vincent
couronne trois petites choses
moi je vais je voulais dire
qu'effectivement alors on dit on met
beaucoup en pause les parties mais
néanmoins quant à la fois on est sur le
terrain on voit c'est très amusant
les gens ne veulent plus de parti mais
mais la première question qui vous pose
c
mais quelle étiquette et de vous c'est
intéressant sur la recomposition sur les
compétences
je voulais juste évoqué la loi nome qui
avait supprimé la clause générale des
collectivités territoriales en 2015
et justement pour essayer pour tenter de
clarifier la complémentarité des
compétences entre les collectivités
territoriales est ainsi pour prendre un
exemple très concret on sait que par
exemple les villes ont la responsabilité
des écoles maternelles et élémentaires
que le département a la responsabilité
des collèges et que la région a la
responsabilité des lycées donc c'est
c'était l'idée voilà mais c'est très
compliqué pour les gens de d'intégrer
évidemment cette notion là
et enfin je rebondissais à la fois sur
ce que vous disiez patrice est ce que
disait vincent sur la sécurité qui est
le thème effectivement dominant des
campagnes électorales qui n'est pas la
compétence par exemple de la région
mais pour y avoir évidemment contribué
sur le vote du budget on voit quand même
que la région a mis plusieurs dizaines
de millions chaque année pour la
sécurité pour compenser en fait là
les déficits de budget de l'état et que
la région a largement contribué à des
choses extrêmement concrètes comme les
commissariats l'équipement des polices
municipales
l'équipement vidéo protection etc et que
les villes ont beaucoup beaucoup
sollicité la région pour avoir ces
subventions pour muscler la sécurité
dans leur commune donc même si ce n'est
pas une compétence première comme la
santé par exemple qui n'est pas une
compétence première
la région est intervenu sur la
résorption des déserts médicaux etc
donc il ya les compétences fabre et il
ya les compétences en fonction un peu
des phénomènes et de la réalité du
terrain de la réalité
déménagement aussi je me souviens de
vincent couronne puisque ce que ce que
dit un père est intéressant sur la
question la sécurité en fait ça démontre
ce qu'on dit depuis tout à l'heure c'est
à dire la complexité de ce magnifique
taurian qui fait que la région dépassant
cette compétence en matière de sécurité
et pourtant il ya de manière assez
ponctuelle ou d'une technique un peu
impressionnistes un peu comme ça agir
sur quelques quelques petits leviers
mémé qui sont créé très indirecte en
réalité ça passe essentiellement par du
financement
si je prends si je prends un exemple le
transport scolaire la loi notre à
transférer les trans la compétence du
transport scolaire du département à la
région
sauf que la loi de l'autre dit également
que la région peut quand même continuer
a confié au département la compétence du
transport scolaire ie6 retrouver
là-dedans
le gouvernement a publié un tableau très
bien fait quatre colonnes pour le dd
détailler les compétences des différents
blocs alors communes intercommunalités
départements régions
le tableau des vins page s'écrit
pétillant et dans chaque colonne vous
avez les mêmes compétences sauf qu'à
chaque fois ce sont pas les mêmes
exceptions les mêmes rogations c'est
incompréhensible
et de ce point de vue là moi je
comprends très bien les lecteurs
qui est un peu perdu il va pas forcément
se déplacer pour ces élections là je
trouve que lier régionales et
départementales le même jour n'est pas
le problème
le problème c'est vraiment la question
de la lisibilité de ce que font chacun
et que cela renforce le point là aussi
pour le coût des stratégies partisanes
et politique parce que justement on
profite du fait qu'on n'y comprennent
rien sur qui fait quoi pour justement de
mettre en avant des jeux d'alliances et
c'est partit alors ce n'est pas fort ce
qui est beaucoup moins le cas pour les
communales les municipales par an donc
voilà donc je trouve que pour parler
pour revenir sur la côte comètes dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
probablement que ces élections
régionales vont être beaucoup plus
intéressante d'un point de vue politique
politique politicienne de ce point de
vue là que ne l'étaient les municipales
auparavant qui était beaucoup plus
concrète seulement juste une dernière
question c'est peut-être sur ces régions
avec vous aujourd'hui jérôme vous avez
étudié évidemment balles et les critères
politiques économiques sociaux qui qui
qui entraîne le vote des électeurs
est ce qu'il ya des grandes différences
selon les régions
mais alors c'est ce qu'on a fait on est
revenu en arrière c'est à dire qu'on a
recomposé les raisons et régions
d'aujourd'hui est depuis 2000 1986 dont
depuis 86 on a fait comme si on avait
les régions d'aujourd'hui et on a essayé
de voir un peu de faire un baromètre je
dirais des compétences et des résultats
et on a on a dressé un tableau qui nous
permet de voir finale seront mitigés
dans ces la politique quant au cdh
économique dire par là qu'il ya des
régions les critères économiques
finalement la normandie koch 505 des
critères économiques c'est-à-dire que
les voyants sont au vert dont tous les
critères et connaître les critères
économiques aussi bien le chômage
la capacité de désendettement l'effort
d'investissement
et donc tous ces aspects qu'on a pu
mesurer par décret dire je vais pas vous
faire la destinée non envoyée à
l'article et qui est formidable parce
qu'il faut avoir en effet d'établir si
ge
mais il ya des différences sans doute de
réaction et de sensations dans le nord
c'est pas la même chose que l'île de
france qui est une région plus riches
etc
enfin il ya évidemment les critères
sociaux sont variables mais il ya ces
critères économiques et les critères
politiques et les aider les gens qui
arrivent à être bonne dans les deux dans
les deux cas c'est le cas par exemple du
grand test de l'occitanie et du centre
val de loire par exemple
et puis à d'autres et gens qui sont très
molle de cada normandie ken politique
est assez proche d'une politique
économique au sens littéral du terme
pareil pour l'île de france et peut-être
pour paca avec quelques exceptions dans
des domaines que ce soit le
désendettement ou les infos par exemple
mais enfin vous lirez en détail dans le
figaro n'arrive réussi à avoir ces
éléments que qui sont qui parle le
goûteur parce que l'impôt l'impôt par
tête bien quand on a un apartheid qu'il
n'augmentait que de 68 euros comme ces
camps et de france contre une moyenne je
crois que c'est plus de 120 quelque 126
ou 130 euros en moyenne sur la moyenne
des régions en france on voit bien quand
même que les choses seraient semble
intéressant pour les peaux pour les
électeurs j'envoie donc cet article qui
s'appelle comment régionales comment
évaluer des critères de choix des
électeurs on peut le retrouver dans le
figaro on va passer au deuxième thème de
cette émission c'est à dire la france de
bach rompt avec cette enquête de du
cevipof qui montre combien nous sommes
pessimistes
[Musique]
je cite cette dernière enquête du
cevipof parmi les critères suivants
qu'est ce qui caractérise votre état
d'esprit actuel alors la lassitude et la
morosité
3 la méfiance enfin c'est terrible quoi
ça c'est pas nouveau - c'est pas nouveau
mais ça n'a strictement rien d'étonnant
on vient on
c'est vrai que c'est une période qui
n'est pas simple un an un an et demi
dans des conditions a construit une
absence totale de liberté
je rappelle que quand même il n'y a pas
de quoi s'enthousiasmer quand on sait
que c'est le premier ministre qui décide
si votre femme peut aller s'acheter une
petite culotte ou pas c'est lui qui
décide des deux ce qui est essentiel ou
pas facile reconnaît les choses on est
quand même la dot donc dans quelque
chose de monstrueux alors au delà de
l'anecdote peau pour le moral c'est
terrible il n'y a pas de quoi être
optimiste
et puis on a ce que ce nom peu de gens
parlent on a un corps médical qui a
vengé les médecins étaient censées
rassurer calme et apaisée hélas dès
qu'il ya une petite accalmie
du côté des politiques les médecins sont
tous là mais attention le variant machin
va arriver attention à la quatrième
vague attention l'explosif avait explosé
cet hiver ça va exploser le printemps
prochain
ça va donc je veux dire mais c'est déjà
bien que les gens aient encore un tout
petit soupçon d'optimisme confiance 6ème
à 21% c'est vrai que la situation n'est
pas facile mais quand quand on regarde
par exemple financial times est
absolument effaré par le pessimisme des
français alors qu'ils disent en
angleterre nombre exit on a eu une
gestion de la crise sanitaire qui était
déplorable on a le problème de l'ecosse
et les anglais sont vaccinés et heureux
charden n'ont donc peut-être qu'il ya
une corrélation entre le fait d'être
vacciné heureux justement parce que ne
m'empêche l'impression que ce qui me
manque beaucoup c'est un peu notre notre
région c'est que justement ce partage
assez conviviale cette manière de deux
débats à plusieurs leno baffe aussi bien
par exemple nos manques cruellement avec
leur condition physique de réunion et
tout ce qu'on pour y retrouver avec la
chaleur du débat donc il ya peut-être un
petit peu de tout ça je pense dans la
dans la morosité ambiante et il faut
savoir aussi que les français
oa d'or cultiver 7 7 7
cette insatisfaction permanente je me
souvient jean-pierre raffarin qui avait
essayé alors qu'il était premier
ministre de faire d'une chanson de ori à
cette époque là un slogan on parle la
positive attitude un levier pour motiver
les français mais bon je ne doute pas
néanmoins dû du pays des lumières pour
montrer que voilà on a l'art de vivre on
a en a on a plein de ressources pour
être heureux mais bon voilà peut-être
aussi sommes nous un petit peu
schopenhauer bien avec avec cette idée
de l'absence de d'avenir on perd un
petit peu de cap mais bon voilà j'ai bon
espoir que ce soit des choses qui avec
la situation sanitaire et son évolution
reprennent un petit peu le dessus et je
tenais aussi à rassurer jean charles les
familles ont pu changer de la sonatt
mans et les rende aussi très malheureuse
plutôt de la fermeture des librairies et
je suis sûr que ça va mais vous savez
que avant le l'enquète du cevipof et
avant la cause il y avait déjà eu une
enquête qu'il resurgit régulièrement et
qui montraient que les français étaient
moins heureux que les afghans oui donc
voilà donc plus pessimistes et bien
après avant avant l'avant la commedia
moi j'ai tout la phrase de de sylvain
tesson est merveilleux c'est la france
et un paradis peuplé de gens qui se
rendent en faire une télé et je crois
que c'est assez juste alors depuis l'es2
puis la copie d castex ça change
mais avant c'était vrai c'est les
fameuses passions tristes de la france
un père brio justement sur les marchés
sur dans les dialogues qu'on va avoir
avec les français comme ça vous sentez
un peu ce set ce pessimisme
je te fais cette lassitude et comme dit
jean charles c'est vrai que on sort
quand même d'un tunnel pas très drôle et
on voit toutes les mesures qui ont été
mis en place d'ailleurs à la région il y
avait une plateforme psy qui avait été
mise en place pour les étudiants et on a
été quand même sidéré de voir
flux de deux consultations demandées
pour un soutien psychologique
on a beaucoup parlé évidemment des
répercussions psychologiques et puis ça
vient s'ajouter à une tendance des
français contrairement aux danois à ne
pas être en haut du tableau des peuples
heureux puisqu'on est classé assez loin
dans le dans le panorama du bonheur sur
l'ensemble des pays effective ou donc ça
plus ça c'est vrai que ces lits pauvre
traduit assez bien l'ambiance et en même
temps 20 secondes on est dans un pays je
sais pas où la vaccination est gratuite
les tests gratuits enfin il ya eu des
aides absolument énorme sur les
entreprises sur le chômage partiel
allez on est quand même un des pays qui
a le plus et jouer aux solidarités non
pendant cette crise oui moi je suis je
suis assez je suis pas très surpris de
ce genre de résultat parce que tout
simplement la france qu'on a l'habitude
est fait comme ça a été dit un juste
avant d'être souvent dans le palmarès
mondial les plus pessimistes
donc pourquoi changer un je veux dire
après tout donc on est fidèles à nous
mêmes
maintenant je dirais que c'est pas
forcément qu'une spécificité
franco-française
il y a une spécificité même plus
européenne en fait à a toujours
considéré qu' on n'est pas forcément les
mieux lotis ou que c'était mieux avant
etc
il ya s'avère un auteur qui s'appelle
rémi brague qui avait écrit un bouquin
qui s'appelle europe la voie romaine qui
est absolument fabuleux et dans lequel
il décrit en fait cette propension des
européens a toujours considéré que et
bien ceux qui les ont précédés étaient
des géants bien meilleur que bien me
dire que nous et ce qui faisait cette
identité un petit peu très spécifique au
continent et qu'il exclut spécifiquement
au royaume uni de cette analyse là où en
europe et bien on avait toujours
tendance à considérer que nous sommes
les héritiers d'un passé un petit peu
glorieux en âge d'or etc et que nous
dévalorise ont aujourd'hui et je pense
que en france à s'exprime peut-être plus
qu'ailleurs mais en tout cas c'est un
petit peu cette tendance là on voit un
peu partout
verdict 0,2 centime aux clés
qu'évoquent les français concernant la
politique c'est l'inquiétude et la
colère
est-ce que c'est dès ce que c'est des
critères que vous avez vues dans les
enquêtes que vous avez pu donner alors
même pas d' enquête directement auprès
des électeurs on ne fait pas des modèles
qu'on peut réaliser ses concurrents du
sondage mais justement c'est très bonne
question dont patrice parce que l'idée
c'est nous ce qu'on cherche à savoir
quelles sont les motivations du vote qu
elles sont hélas quelles sont les
raisons de la colère
quelles sont les raisons de cette peur
et de cette inquiétude pour ce faire on
regarde les indicateurs d'une sceller
les anticipations des ménages tel que
révélé par les enquêtes de l'insee
notamment et ce que l'on voit là
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya des
anticipations très négatives elles sont
négatives en termes d'anticipation de
chômage concernant les anticipations de
niveau de vie et les anticipations
d'inflation qui remonte et là on ne peut
que que qu'adhérer à cette idée parce
que aux états unis on voit que
l'inflation repart et repart
sérieusement et de façon marquée et donc
les électeurs sont dans cette situation
les français sont dans cette situation
où on comprend bien le déconfinement ne
suffira pas ce n'est pas tout et puis le
quoi qu'il en coûte
ils savent très bien que ça aura une fin
alors il ya deux types de réactions
possibles c je suis ce qu'on appelle en
économie vulgairement un freerider
c'est-à-dire un opportuniste quelqu'un
qui se dit et qui demande aux politiques
de dépenser plus
à partir du moment tant que cette
dépense publique par l essor tant
qu'elle est financée en puisant dans la
poche du voisin donc si c'est le voisin
qui financent et que moi je profite
je suis entièrement d'accord pour plus
encore de dépenses à partir du moment où
je participe au financement j'ai une
vision un peu plus je dirais rigoureuse
des choses donc le retour des électeurs
sera là encore un peu un peu ambigu un
peu c'est un peu janus électeurs parce
que il veut à la fois plus de dépenser
moins d'impôts or l'impôt financer
dépenses et le discours qu étaient eux
généré véhiculée par le président alors
on peut le comprendre je ne critique pas
le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est une façon de rassurer la
population disant pandémie liée
situation exceptionnelle dépenses
exceptionnelles mais les lecteurs il se
il arrive un moment
le français va se les français vont se
dire ça aura une fin ça aura bien une
fin donc il doit bien comprendre que
plus de dépenses ça voudra dire un jour
et ça c'est un je dirais c'est
l'arbitrage qui est fait c'est de le
principe pour une économie plus de
dépenses elle peut se traduire que par
deux choses n'y a pas trente six mille
solutions c'est soit plus d'impôts soit
plus d'entrain c'est la dette cds impôts
futurs
donc c'est une équivalence ricardienne
ce qu'on appelle en économie n'est
qu'ils balancent gardienne c'est à dire
que si je dépense plus de toute façon il
faudra rembourser un jour le débat qu'il
ya eu au début d'année sur l'endettement
disant ça ne coûte rien les taux
d'intérêt sont très bas remonte
d'ailleurs et ce n'est pas grave on
pourra effacer d'un date d'un coup
d'épongé la dette ce n'est pas possible
il y aura toujours quelqu'un qui paiera
directement ou indirectement et donc je
pense que les lecteurs
ni pas dupes ils voient bien que plus de
dépenses ça se paiera un jour tôt ou
tard et si emmanuel macron aéré lui il
est possible que dans le dans la lah
l'ambiance de ce qu'on appelle la l'état
grâce au nez moon une fois élus et bien
ton arrive au pouvoir on vient et très
bien avec une majorité donc forcément un
soutien on va puiser dans ce soutien et
il prendra peut-être les mesures de
rigueur que normalement tout cas c'est
ce que l'on voit dans le site économique
politico-économique dans le business
ricol il fera les mesures de rigueur
d'elad et sa réélection peut être encore
plus facilement parce qu'il ne pensera
pas n'envisagera pas un troisième mandat
donc pour lui la politique aura une fin
et donc il pourra peut-être de mettre un
peu d'eux un peu un peu d'ordre dans
tout ça donc je pense que l'électeur a
quand même quand il s'agit du porte
monnaie
il a un il est passé un peu avec
peut-être rebondir sur ce que disait
jean chatroussat quand même unité
en effet les français sont souvent plus
malheureux que les afghans et en fait on
concède que c'est une tendance des pays
développés a précisément avoir toujours
besoin de plus et ça rejoint un peu la
logique de l'emprunt comme le disait
léon gérôme c'est à dire qu'en fait on
se rend compte que ce ne sont que les
pays développés qui recourt à l'emprunt
à l'endettement et à la dépense publique
et à une espèce de j'ai envie de
de narco addiction à la dépense et à
l'emprunt parce que précisément il est
aussi une logique de 2
j'ai envie de dire de développement par
l'économie qui est un peu dangereuse et
peut-être que le confinement en tout cas
étaient censés nous aider à ça c'est à
dire que plus on dépense plus qu'on veut
et puis on est développée plus on a
tendance à tout vouloir et du coup on
est un peu dans cette logique ça les
pays développés eux arrivent à moins
développés de bonheur à soi il ya
toujours cette idée du qu'on peut avoir
et donc c'est une espèce de fuite en
avant alors est temps de changer de vie
il est possible aussi que la crise
sanitaire renforce un peu le le côté
égoïste de chacun et que bon allez
génération je dise ça sera les
générations futures qui paie cran de
reporter aux forêts il y avait cette
solidarité qu'on avait vu avec le la
montée du mouvement écologique c'était
quelques haltères on va laisser à nos
enfants et là peut-être qu'avec la crise
au fond chacun chaque heure et gap ce
qui est bon pour soi on va passer
je vais peut-être remercie véronique
gens que j'aurais voulu on n'a pas le
temps de l'aborder mais l'interview de
deux de du président de la république de
hasagic dans lequel il parle notamment
d'un gilet jaune et de cette jacquerie
française qui est constitutif de
l'esprit français qui et c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui a été souvent
les présidents de la république je suis
ravisé vaut mieux rien faire ne rien
bouger parce que sinon ça risque
d'exploser à tout moment
verdict demain on va on aura le temps
d'en parler de notre foi verdict 0 merci
infiniment merci patrice passé à tous et
je renvoie donc à votre article
régionales il reste sur les bijoux le
reste il reste quatre minutes 1 re
édition
alors on va vous regarder je voudrais
qu'on parle juste du retour quand même
dur fin du retour du complotisme qui se
porte de mieux en mieux
semble-t-il
[Musique]
selon charles alors vous avez vu notre
ami jean marie bigard mais il y avait
bon après il est ce qu'il est il dit ce
qu'il dit mais il y avait à côté de lui
une généticienne qui s'appelle alexandra
envrion coude et c'est ça qui est plus
intéressant c'est qu'au fond et qui est
une part intime qui a été une très bonne
année 10 yens ce qui est pourtant plus
intéressant c'est que des scientifiques
on a toujours l'impression que les
scientifiques sont pour la vaccination
la science et ça c'est pas tout à fait
vrai il ya beaucoup de scientifiques qui
sont contre la vaccination parce que ils
disent que des procès ceux habituels
n'ont pas été respectées et donc ils
nourrissent aussi le groupe le 10 mai
oui mais c'est le drame c'est
probablement de de noyer tout ça dans un
ce terme de complotisme oui il ya une
certaine régulière l'ouverture de doxa
médical qui veut que ça soit bien le
vaccin ça soit bien de se faire vacciner
etc je suis à fond pour c'est très bien
je connais rien je pas médecin je leur
fais confiance
mais je trouve tout à fait normal qu'ils
aient des voix dissonantes encore medien
et dès qu'ils aient une voix dissonante
et c'est pas hélas que dans le domaine
médical tout de suite ces gens sont
ostracisés et du coup alors en dire bah
oui ils sont maintenant dans n'importe
quelle dîners en ville ne va pas dîner
en ville avant dans quel bon j'arrive je
vais êtes déjeuner en ligne et bien des
cons et des terrasses voilà dès qu'on
n'est pas pour quelque chose pour ce que
tout le monde pense on soutient pas le
gouvernement sur la lutte contre la
colline on est complotistes et ben non
on peut être contre le vaccin sans être
un abruti absolue monsieur a priori je
suis pour mais signe aucune compétence
médicale non je ne sais pas peut-être
que je me trouve je n'en sais rien mais
je ne suis pas complotistes et les gens
qui décèdent généticienne est peut-être
très intelligente pourquoi pourquoi est
ce que je serai le corps et les horse et
il n'y a pas de raison intervenant en
homo parce qu'il ne reste plus plus de
deux minutes maintenant
mais certains disent que cette montée ça
vient du fait ou fait s'il n'y a pas de
débat quoi il ya une montée des dettes
technique il n'y a pas de débat sur
l'utilisation philosophique débat
sociétal sur l'utilisation de ces
techniques
c'est vrai néanmoins je rajoute une
chose jean charles a parlé de confiance
je n'y connais rien à la médecine et
confiance et je crois que c'est cela
complotisme c'est qu'il n'y a plus
confiance en france et je pense que
c'est un bon temps avec les réseaux
sociaux avec l'internet qu'il faut que
quand on a une consultation médecin
maintenant on a tendance à taper sur
google et à regarder sur doctissimo et à
se penser plus compétentes un peu
dangereux ça nous arrive en droit vous
arrive en médecine ça nous arrive
partout et de confiance qui fait que
chacun est un expert est secondé de
créer un danger parce que justement du
coup il n'y a plus de spécialistes il
n'y a plus de confiance et donc du coup
le débat ce bruit puisque chacun a son
propre avis alors néanmoins c'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut pas qui le
dépasse il était il faut peut-être juste
trouver le bon équilibre entre croire en
des personnes qui ont plus de
compétences tout simplement et
développer aussi des débats à
l'intérieur d'une discipline mais pour
moi le débat ne doit pas amener à ce que
chacun puisse se considérer compétents
la compétence quand même la clé
l'intelligence et la pacification des
relations sociales en ce sens ça
rappelle le très bon texte d' etienne
klein qui s'appelait je ne suis pas
médecin mais où il reprenait tous ces
politiques enfin tous ces gens qui
intervenait en dire je ne suis pas
médecin mais j'ai quand même un
avertissement la question en eau en ont
même année pour conclure oui mais c'est
vite parce qu'il 20 secondes
oui alors c'est vrai que l'état
l'autorité de l'état et l'autorité
médicale fait que ça n'est pas très
enclin aux débats à la base et pour
rejoindre lens arles
moi j'ai deux je trouve que vu cette
fulgurance d'avoir trouvé ce vaccin il
est normal et légitime de se poser car à
des questions à soi même en tant
qu'individu voilà et puis la deuxième
question qui peut être aussi légitime
sans être complotistes ces deux se dit
en fait
est ce que cette pandémie n'est pas
parti malgré tout d'une d'une petite
négligence d'un laboratoire qui
manipulent quand même d'aider des choses
extrêmement dangereuse
et alors pas du tout intentionnellement
comme je les ai vus voilà mais est-ce
qu'on peut pas quand même légitimement
se poser la question d'une erreur
technique sautel complotistes c'est vrai
que c'est une possibilité qu'on peut
poser des questions sans être heures en
effet montré du doigt comme comme
complotite merci infiniment à tous les
cinq bercy véronique jérôme je rappelle
le titre de votre article régional
comment évaluer les critères de choix
des électeurs merci beaucoup et charlène
bezina du club une paire brio vincent
couronne et jean charles lajoie dis à
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
boeuf
[Musique]